so i promise to destroy your world  in 10 days the galaxy needs its  guardians  you said this would be a relaxing  holiday  the summer of love today today that will  go down in history and thunder begins  today we'll fight  this is my vow oh god shrunk down  them they may not be catastrophic to the  whole universe  thor love and thunder in peter july a  rated pg-13  so that's the ex-girlfriend is it  the old ex-girlfriend judy foster jane  foster the one that got away the one  that got away  that means escaped yeah  yeah  must be hard for you to see your  ex-girlfriend and your ex hammer hanging  out and getting on so well  [Music]  what you have to bring  [Music]  to daddy  [Music]  hey  there you  i was are calling you